vivemos em busca de uma vida feliz não é
mesmo a palavra felicidade parece que
vem junto com a palavra perfeição vida
perfeita para muitas pessoas uma vida
perfeita pode ser viajar
comer bem é ter uma bela família ter uma
um casamento enfim eu já tinha tudo isso
eu tinha um casamento maravilhoso uma
filha já com seis anos
linda e maravilhosa eu já viajava por
vários lugares do mundo
eu comia bem enfim eu já tinha muitas
coisas
a minha vida era um verdadeiro conto de
fadas
elas lhe ia fui parecia que nada iria
acontecer até que o nascimento da minha
segunda filha
eu lembro que minha segunda filha ela
foi muito mas muito desejada
a gente ficou tentando ela é dois anos
fizemos uma série de exames em nada nada
aparentemente parecia é que a gente
tinha algum problema enfim não tínhamos
nenhum problema então resolvemos após
dois anos
optar pela inseminação artificial até aí
tudo bem mesmo a gente faz inseminação
artificial
fizemos e não é que de primeira ela
resolveu aparecer
fiquei grávida ea gestação foi
maravilhosa
só parecia um nos exames do pré natal
então só parecia uma criança linda
maravilhosa e perfeita crescendo antes
de mim até com 37 semanas ela resolveu
nascer ela eu entrei em trabalho de
parto
fui correndo para o hospital e meu
marido não fomos correndo pro hospital
estão correndo gente quer esquecer a mãe
do segundo já está esquecido levar uma
ala da maternidade com a roupa do corpo
e ela nasceu embrulhadinho nos lençóis
da maternidade de 37
humanos geralmente os bebezinhos nascem
de 39 40 semanas mas ela resolveu se
adiantar eu lembro que devido àquela
confusão aquela correria
o que eu mais assim tenho a imagem é
dela no meu colo aquela carinha linda
maravilhosa olhando pra mim é tipo uma
mãe cuida de mim
irritada eu fiquei muito feliz em quem
só que na maternidade onde eu tive
minhas duas filhas
o sistema diferente às crianças os bebês
nascem mas eles não ficam direto na no
quarto junto com os pais eles acabam
indo pro berçário e foi o que aconteceu
com a bruna ela foi para o berçário
só que ela foi mas ela não voltava ela
eu sabia que alguma coisa de errado
estava acontecendo né
mas ainda não sabia o que estava
acontecendo até que três homens entrou
no meu quarto na maternidade que é o meu
pai o meu marido e um pediatra de
plantão
eu lembro que o rosto deles estavam
apavorados e não tinha nenhum sorriso no
rosto deles
aquela situação de angústia
profundamente eu falei pelo amor de deus
o que está acontecendo até que o
pediatra de plantão falou que minha
filha nasceu com síndrome de down
valeu como se fosse hoje eu sentei na
cama da maternidade e assim fiquei sem
chão
como assim sempre me down né
eu tinha uma visão que a síndrome de
down era é pessoas limitadas vegetativas
que viviam sempre dependendo de uma
outra pessoa
eu também tinha uma visão errada sobre
isso a minha ignorância
eu levei um susto porque a minha vida
era um conto de fadas ela era perfeita
como a síndrome de down síndrome de down
não acontece comigo ela acontece com o
outro
como assim comigo eu
foi um momento muito difícil pra mim
principalmente vinha na minha imagem o
preconceito
eu tinha muito medo da sociedade
eu tinha medo do julgamento eu larguei
minha profissão de jornalista também
tornar mãe e eu não sabia o que queria
proteger ela de alguma maneira e eu
entrei num no luto profundo
só chorava chorava
eu não via um futuro de possibilidades
até que a minha segunda minha primeira
filha júlia que na época com apenas seis
anos de idade que entrou no quarto para
ver a irmã e viu chorando e chegou pra
mim e falou assim mamãe a julho
mamãe para de chorar
eu não estou vendo nada de diferente na
bruna a gente não ama o duque o do que
eu não sou cachorro que é um spitz
alemão
lulu da pomerânia que era pra ser o
cachorro mais pelo de fofinho e ele
perdeu os pêlos devido uma condição
genética ea júlia falava pra mim assim
mamãe a gente não ama o duque
do jeito que ele é com pêlos em pelo
agente vai amarrar bruna do jeito que
ela é
e ela é perfeita perfeita
tá aí uma palavra perfeita e entrou
aquelas palavras ditas pela minha filha
com apenas seis anos de idade entraram
de uma forma e eu comecei a enxergar
possibilidades e eu vi meu marido que
sempre me deu um apoio muito grande e
elas juntas
eu vi aquela cena e falei não chega a
partir de agora tudo vai mudar e nós
vamos enfrentar essa situação da melhor
maneira possível
vamos vencer tudo afinal de contas o
principal a gente já tem que é muito
amor envolvido
e foi a partir daí que a gente resolveu
e atrás
informações então o que é essa tal de
síndrome de down né vamos conhecer aí a
gente começou a perceber que a síndrome
de down nada mais é que um um cromossoma
mais no cromossomo número 21
nós pessoas típicas
temos 46 cromossomos a pessoa com
síndrome time tinha síndrome de down ela
tem 47
tá e que isso significa significa que
esse excesso de carga genética é pode
provocar um atraso tanto no
desenvolvimento é intelectual quanto de
aprendizagem aprendizagem e
desenvolvimento da pessoa com síndrome
de down e eu também descobri que
diferente de outra condição a síndrome
de down não tem grau não terá um grau 2
grau 3
a pessoa com síndrome de down vai se
desenvolver
de acordo com o meio em que ela nasce
de acordo com as estimulações
estimulações precoce e também de acordo
com o acolhimento o acolhimento tanto da
família quanto da sociedade
isso mesmo eu você vocês todos nós somos
responsáveis pelo desenvolvimento de uma
pessoa com síndrome de down pois o
acolhimento faz total diferença na vida
delas
a minha filha ela sempre foi muito
iluminada muito amada porque porque a
gente aceitou a condição genética dela
de uma maneira tão natural que hoje em
dia a gente enxerga a síndrome de down
ela hoje com 3 anos estudam em uma
escola regular
o acolhimento que ela recebe nessa
escola é maravilhoso o acolhimento dos
profissionais
o acolhimento dos professores da
professora dela que inclusive faz um
trabalho assim extraordinário com ela
o acolhimento dos amiguinhos dela da
sala de aula e também o acolhimento dos
pais
mas desses amiguinhos eles fazem um
duelo tão grande com a gente que a gente
se sente muito incluído e eu tenho
certeza que faz total diferença no
sucesso do desenvolvimento da minha
filha mas nem sempre foi assim
a minha filha a primeira escola que eu
fui atrás quer uma escola particular é a
existia uma vaga para uma criança na
idade dela mas a partir do momento que
eu cheguei na escola eu falei que minha
filha tem síndrome de down
essa vaga deixou de existir e uma série
de empecilhos apareceram para que ela
não pudesse é é a não pudesse estar
nessa vaga naquela situação me deixou
muito mas muito frustrada como mãe
porque eu me senti impotente foi a
primeira vez que eu me senti impotente
que eles nem chegaram a conhecer a minha
filha e já rotularam ela a palavra
síndrome de down foi maior do que a
palavra ser humano uma condição genética
à síndrome de down que essa condição
genética ela não limita as
possibilidades o que limita a
possibilidade é o preconceito é a falta
de informação ea falta de se colocar no
lugar do outro
tenho certeza que se a gente colocasse
mais um lugar do outro
o mundo seria bem melhor e o mundo o
mundo dá voltas e é cheio de surpresas
que garante que no futuro vocês não
possam estar aqui desse lado a palavra
aqui não é inclusão
a palavra é respeito respeito à base o
respeito pelo próximo respeito pela
diversidade
feito pelas diferenças afinal de contas
todos nós somos diferentes um é alto da
noite outra morena é isso que torna nós
seres humanos pessoas especiais
as nossas diferenças e o que mais assim
me essas diferenças que deixam nós cada
vez mais unidos porque porque somos
seres humanos e de se devemos respeitar
todos da mesma forma
minha filha é eu eu cheguei com a
surpresa né eu falo com relação ao
respeito mas também o mundo e lhe dá
muitas voltas como eu mencionei mas eu
posso dizer uma coisa a gente não tem um
controle de nada nessa vida com toda
certeza servir uma situação que era pra
ser uma situação é foi mais frustrante
da minha vida que foi a que me encheu de
possibilidades
ela me deu um rumo uma verdadeira missão
no ato que eu descobrir com susto nesta
notícia da síndrome de down
eu confesso para vocês que naquele
momento do susto da notícia da falta de
informação sobre a síndrome de down de
uma diversidade que estava acontecendo
nela com relação à saúde dela
ela apresentava o teste do pezinho dava
negativo teste ela teve pouquíssimo mia
e o medo do preconceito me fez pensar em
segundos mas me fez pensar que se deus
levar se ela seria melhor seria melhor
para nós seria melhor para ela porque
ela não teria que enfrentar uma
sociedade que prejulga antes de conhecer
moça mas eu fui muito boba muito boba
pensar isso mesmo que por um segundo
porque hoje a minha vida não faz
sem ela e as lágrimas de tristeza
hoje são lágrimas de alegria lágrimas de
alegria pelo progresso dela
lágrimas de alegria pelas pequenas
vitórias e por ela me mostrar que ela é
capaz assim como todos nós somos capazes
ela hoje é uma pessoa muito mais feliz
do que eu
sim porque ela enxerga o mundo com
leveza ela enxerga o mundo com o amor
ela enxerga detalhes que nós adultos né
não conseguimos ver por exemplo a árvore
batendo neoview vento batendo na árvore
mexendo as folhinhas o a lua no céu
coisas que nós não paramos pra ver
porque a gente está passando pela vida a
gente não tá vivendo a vida e esse olhar
dela e eu chego a dizer que o olhar da
júlia também olhar para as duas e olhar
de todas as crianças que o olhar de
pureza é um olhar de igualdade é um
olhar que permite sermos quem somos sem
julgamentos
eu eu aprendi que se nós trabalharmos é
esse olhar
nós podemos mudar o nosso mundo
podemos ter uma vida muito mais feliz
uma vida muito mais leve emercom menos
preconceitos e pré julgamentos porque é
com todo essas ações nos podemos ser
melhor ea minha filha com certeza me deu
esse olhar ea minha vida ela é perfeita
a minha vida sempre foi perfeita ea
minha vida feliz e nós se conseguirmos
trabalhar mas esse olhar isso com
certeza podemos ser bem felizes até
porque a perfeição que a forma como a
gente enxerga e significa a nossa vida
se quer chamar aqui no palco as pessoas
que fizeram total e fazem total
diferença na minha vida
e transforma a ela uma vida perfeita
minha família
por favor uma cláusula para ela e meu
marido e as minhas duas filhas julho e
bruna que são as minhas verdadeiras
professoras e que permitem que eu te
costa cada dia mas ser uma pessoa melhor
e eu aprendi com tudo isso que nós
podemos fazer a diferença nesse mundo e
principalmente fazer a diferença no
mundo de uma pessoa especial e quem
acredita que o que também pode fazer
essa diferença levante as mãos porque
juntos somos mais fortes
obrigada
[Aplausos]